digamos que tenemos alguna sustancia
misteriosa aquí y sabemos que es un
elemento puro y tenemos que descubrir
que es bueno los científicos tienen un
método que vemos con más detalle en
otros vídeos llamado espectrometría de
masas o también espectroscopia de masas
es una técnica en la que podemos tomar
una muestra de una sustancia y
considerar las diversas masas atómicas
de los diferentes isótopos en esa
sustancia y esto es lo que tenemos justo
aquí nos dicen que el espectro de masas
para una muestra promedio de un elemento
puro se muestra a continuación entonces
digamos que este es el elemento puro lo
que esto nos dice es que parece que el
82% de nuestra muestra tiene una masa
atómica de 88 unidades de masa atómica
unificadas aproximadamente el 7% de
nuestra muestra tiene una masa atómica
de 87 unidades de masa atómica
unificadas parece que el 10 por ciento
tiene una masa atómica de 86 unidades de
masa atómica unificadas y parece que
aproximadamente el 1 por ciento de
nuestra muestra tiene una masa atómica
de 84 unidades de masa
unificadas a partir de esta información
podemos intentar estimar cuál es la masa
atómica promedio de este elemento
misterioso podríamos calcularlo como el
0.82 por 88 más digamos que esto es 7%
entonces 0.07 por 87 más 10 por ciento
0.1 por 86 más veamos debería sumar 100
por ciento esto es 89 y luego nos lleva
a 99 entonces otro 1 por ciento 0.01 por
84 y esta es nuestra estimación de la
masa atómica promedio de este elemento
podríamos usar una calculadora y obtener
un número y luego buscarlo en la tabla
periódica de los elementos o simplemente
podríamos tratar de estimar lo podemos
ver que va a estar cerca de 88 porque
ahí es donde está el porcentaje más alto
cuando tenemos el promedio ponderado
tenemos el mayor peso justo aquí pero
estos otros isótopos estas otras
versiones del elemento que tienen un
número diferente de neutrones lo que
cambia su masa atómica
van a reducir el promedio entonces
nuestra masa atómica promedio será un
poco menor que 88 así que veamos la
tabla periódica de los elementos que
elemento aquí tiene una masa atómica un
poco menor que 88 bueno el itrio tiene
88 punto 91 pero sabemos que no puede
ser ese porque ninguno de los isótopos
tiene una masa atómica superior a 88 el
estroncio se ve bastante bien es
exactamente lo que predijimos un poco
menos de 88 y el rubidio es mucho menos
de 88 entonces incluso si no hiciéramos
el cálculo podríamos sentirnos seguros
de que no va a ser tan bajo como el
rubidio por lo tanto me siento muy
confiada con sólo mirarlo con solo
estimar lo de que tendrá una masa
atómica promedio un poco menor que 88 lo
que nos dice que esto es estroncio